question should everyone be doing coffee animals? Well, it depends on what you mean by everybody.
If you mean every cancer patient, yeah, probably, yes. But I would say it partly depends on where
you're at with your cancer. So I feel like I'm in full remission right now. I haven't done coffee
animals. I think I did, I had a week of doing coffee animals about six months ago if I remember
so I was having some issues. But it was probably six months before that that I did them.
So I don't do weekly or daily coffee animals anymore. But if you're in the throes of your
cancer, do a daily coffee animals, I'd say yes. If you're in your throes of your cancer,
you're having issues with detoxification, you're having issues with anxiety, you're having issues
with your immune system, you're having issues with constipation, you could do multiple coffee
animals per day. Max Gerson used to recommend people that are in later stage cancers that they're
doing five coffee animals a day. How could they possibly do five coffee animals a day? It takes me
half an hour to do a coffee animal. Well, you go on our site and you do the easy peasy way to do a
coffee animal. So we talked about this last week or the week before too, the easy peasy way of coffee
doing coffee animals. They're going to definitely stimulate a person to do coffee animals more often
because it's super easy. Hence in the name, so you're just doing them in the shower standing,
you're not rolling on your side and on your back, making a mess, worried about you're going to spill
all over and have to clean that up and do all that doing the easy peasy way of doing coffee animals
is just that easy peasy.